hey you guys max with max tech today we
are gonna be testing out and comparing
the gaming performance between the brand
new Galaxy s5 II and Apple's new iPad
air 3 as you may know vadim is the one
who typically does ease gaming
comparisons but he is on a well-deserved
vacation so today you have me my skill
level for games is nowhere near Vadim's
of what we're still gonna have a little
bit of fun and see can this even compete
or get close to the iPad which we know
is the powerhouse with this a12 Bionic
processor with this faster processor I
also want to check out the low times
because that could make a big difference
in the day-to-day there we have it took
36 seconds with the iPad and with the
galaxy there we go a minute in 30
seconds that's close to three times as
long okay first impressions this looks
terrible I know if you guys could tell
in the camera wow it defaulted to
quality low 20 frames per second and
only 75 percent resolution we can't do
20 frames per second it has to be at
least 30 is it literally not letting me
even go to medium settings this is not a
good sign okay and with the iPad air
look at the graphics in the lobby that
looks nice let's hop into the settings
here and defaulted or an epic 100% 30
FPS if we want we can switch over to 60
frames per second it's gonna lower it
down to high frame rate I like better
graphics so I'm gonna go to epic we're
gonna match the frame rate between the
two right in the party bus it shows 30
frames per second I hear somebody no I
don't have a gun oh please give me stuff
all right
you know what I realized I think this is
the first time I'm playing fortnight on
mobile I played it on PC maybe I should
have been able to tap anywhere okay
where is this guy
I you're right behind me well I got one
little stutter there and now it looks to
be back to normal
is that a gun no go and do that to me
where are you where are you where are
you is he above me what well it's
where's my gun though
it's kind of hard to tell where they're
coming from when the sound is just from
the right side over here let's see if I
have any better luck with the s5e and oh
my goodness I cannot believe the
graphics how is this possible
we're comparing epic to low yes ammo
whoa
stutter it's the moment of truth did I
kill him did I kill him oh my goodness
okay I hear more people it definitely is
easier to hear where somebody is coming
from with the stereo speakers in there
oh if they're up there okay
take that take that No Oh respawning Oh
I sell my shotgun nice I think I might
actually start playing for tonight I did
not know you could respawn previously
you'd spend like five ten minutes trying
to get some good stuff Garrity and then
you just instantly die somebody Snipes
you and I felt like a big waste of time
for me oh okay where's it being shot
from somewhere over here
whoo there we go okay where are okay why
am I getting glitches I don't think I
kill oh I did kill him oh okay but I
feel like I'm just a camper here whoa
okay okay
no he's sniping me okay take that all
right so I'm actually having a pretty
good time playing here I just really
wish that those times where I'm running
around especially when I'm actually in
an active firefight I'm trying to shoot
somebody they didn't get those little
glitches and framedrops even though I'm
low it can't keep up at 30 frames per
second oh oh no no no dude come on come
on come on Fonda so the sound is pretty
nice it's definitely more immersive it's
not as heavy but even at low resolution
30 frames per second I'm getting these
glitches where it's going down it's like
I don't know 15 stuttering for you know
a split second and if you're an active
firefight and you start glitching up
that's definitely gonna affect your
performance and you're gonna get killed
whereas if you're playing with the iPad
you wouldn't and on top of the graphics
are way better so I can enjoy myself but
man I really wish I was playing on the
iPad right now all right now it's time
for asphalt 9 let's see how long it
takes to load up that was like 9 seconds
or so so not that much slower about 12
seconds not bad
oh I like the song legends
shout out to everybody who watches Gary
Vee out there change our controls this
game has an awesome soundtrack and man
with these quad speakers awesome another
interesting thing is gotta sit down on
the speakers man too loud we have a
visual quality setting here high quality
or default I'm gonna go to high quality
because I like my stuff to look good a
lot of aliasing
I'm getting a little confused about to
touch this dear there we go
yeah there you go come on come on
nitrous nitrous nitrous
yes okay a lot less a loosening
definitely a lot less a wasting this
looks much nicer get out of my way get
out of my way yeah almost no aliasing
super smooth and the graphics look nice
I mean really nice the speakers aren't
as loud even though they're maxed out
back to the s5e I'm gonna max out the
speaker so you guys can hear the
difference between these two Wow two
hours but I'm gonna keep it on yeah oh
my goodness these graphics
don't compare no I knew that my true
[Music]
[Applause]
okay we're done let's turn that down Wow
so my speakers are maxed out on the iPad
now it doesn't sound too loud better
bass better low-end
let me get it but it's fine
not as immersive not as much in your
face yep all right nitro
I could do with a little bit more volume
on this one honestly compared to the
last one especially with cool music as
long as you're not gonna annoy people
these graphics look like my xbox
graphics seriously they look fantastic
and it's super smooth no glitching no
stuttering I don't know what the
framerate is but it looks great last
time with the s spivey here yeah yeah a
lot of aliasing a lot of aliasing
graphics don't look as good speakers are
nice
this makes me feel like I'm playing a
mobile game another thing I noticed is
how much more comfortable is to hold us
in your hand no no no no down down
please
ah as close so close yeah it's much more
comfortable to hold in your hand when
you're playing I read case so what are
my takeaways from this gaming
performance well going into this video I
already knew that the graphics
performance of the s5e are about one
third of the iPad pros a 12 processor in
my hands on comparison I ran some
different benchmarks and I was shocked
by how much of a difference there is
even though both these tablets are kind
of in the same price range and then
looking out for a night when we got into
that it defaulted to low graphics
settings they wouldn't let me go any
higher and defaulted to 20 frames per
second and at 70% resolution and that
has to say something and it did as soon
as we got into the game even though I
had bumped it up to 30 it really wasn't
able to stick at 30 we got a lot of
glitches and it really did hurt the
performance if you want to get serious
with your gaming it's gonna hold you
back now in asphalt 9 it's not that bad
it did let me go up higher of what that
said there were some glitches and the
graphics really looked like you know a
couple years ago the graphics that you
would get with mobile games whereas the
iPad air 3 looks phenomenal and asphalt
9 I mean same thing in its fortnight I
just I can't say for tonight has
phenomenal graphics but for what for a
night it is it looks really great and
it's smooth and that's about 9 it looks
really good and it's super smooth so if
you're into gaming the iPad air 3 is
definitely better device I think most of
you guys probably knew that my biggest
question is how does it feel for gaming
I know it's not gonna be as good as iPad
air 3 but overall I just really cannot
recommend it if it's performing this
poorly with such low graphics settings
right now think about a year from now
two years from now maybe three years
from now it is gonna be terrible so let
me know your thoughts down in the
comments section below
I'd love to hear your guys's opinion
Lizabeth max max tech hit that little
circle of vibe if you want to see more
videos like this one including my full
review of the galaxy s5 II thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
one